after covert the scariest thing in the
world for me is a central bank digital
currency because I don't think people
understand the implications of what a
central bank digital currency does and I
think for those people who are hearing
about this for for the first time or not
that affair with what it actually means
right now if you've got dollars in your
hand you can spend those dollars how you
wish because there's always going to be
a buyer or a taker to take those dollars
out of your hand but when there's a
central bank digital currency the
government can literally because it's
all digital they can control where you
spend and what you spend and they can
catch you off at one point if they own
the central the central Hub of the
legend one Ledger if it's on one Ledger
if it's on one Ledger and that is what
they're gearing up for they're gearing
up for Central Bank digital currency now
just I mean let's just quickly compare
Central Bank digital currency with what
happened with covert so during covert
there were there were um we had to stay
at home and there were curfews and you
had to be at home
past a certain time and you couldn't go
in the morning now one way to enforce
that is to just say hey guys you can't
leave and if you do leave you better be
part of the uh um
essential workers oh I was going to say
Gavin Newsom is a private part another
way to do it another way to do it is to
just cut off your spending and basically
say you listen you cannot spend money
between 10 AM and 10 pm cannot spend
money wherever you go you will not be
able to touch money under your bank
account
that is a very very scary scenario let
me give you just a practical example say
you have a baby and your baby needs
diapers and you have a little emergency
you go to the store you want to get
yourself a set of diapers you walk into
the store you grab the diapers you try
and pay for the diapers and say sorry
the government said that you can't spend
money between X and Y let's take it one
step further government doesn't want you
to eat red meat anymore just doesn't
want you to eat too much red meat you
want to go and pay for your steak
they'll say sorry you've had you've had
eight Stakes this month
that is the power that we give
governments if we get a central bank I
would also add issuing credit based on
narrative instead of Merit so as an
example you know if you take everything
out of the one balance sheet the FED
can't go bust
so they can issue loans they don't need
to be paid back they could care less so
you don't need to give them a credit
score
so what happens is Adam goes down to the
local bank you know you got to talk to
Jerome Powell to get your next mortgage
and they say hey you know what we heard
what you said the other day yeah Pat
yeah that ain't gonna happen your social
score is a negative 10 or whatever but
Dylan Mulvaney
goes to Wells Fargo and the throwing
money at him and he's got a 500 credit
score why because he is part of that
group that is part of that political
narrative you see that that woke
narrative and and that's why having that
all those deposits on the same Ledger is
so crucial for them to implement these
orwellian policies that all of us should
be extremely concerned with but the
focus needs to be not so much on the
cbdc but all of those deposits going
onto one Ledger that's what people have
to push back against and the good news
here is that it's currently illegal if
you go to the fed's website they say
that it is illegal for them to hold
accounts of individuals so we all need
to be cognizant of that so if they try
to change that law or if they try to
circumvent that law that we can hold
them accountable and that's what this is
all about who would lead the charge in
the United States for that to actually
be implemented well Jerome Powell is the
one that's been speaking about it so
Jerome part is the one that has
mentioned that they were looking into a
digital Central Bank digital currency by
the way if you think that this is very
far away it's not like in China it's
happening in China they've they they
they have been dealing with Central Bank
digital currencies for for many many
years and there is a festival I think it
might even be Chinese New Year where the
idea is that you give a red envelope and
inside the Red Envelope is a gift and
the gift is a certain you know whatever
it is and they actually did a campaign
in China where they had a red envelope
campaign but with a cbdc so that people
actually adopt a cbdc to see how much
money that how much money they've got
and that's an adoption tool once people
get used to using the Central Bank
digital currency you've given the
government the ultimate power have they
already implemented a social credit
score in China is that actually social
credit scores in China but remember it's
not the Central Bank digital currency is
not yet Mass adopted there is a list I
don't have the website but there's some
website that actually shows a list of
all countries and how close or how far
they are from being able to to implement
a digital currency a central bank
digital currency what's at the top of
the list I think China and I think
there's like African countries there
like I think Nigeria I I can check the
tweet in a second but for me the the
scariest thing is if we get a central
bank digital currency you have got to
make sure that as much of your money on
the day that that Central Bank digital
currency is a reality you got to get as
much of your money into a neutral system
as possible yeah unfortunately I think
you're gonna have a problem there as
well that people really need to be
cognizant first of all you know they you
never let a good crisis go to waste so
if we have a banking crisis the FDIC
comes in they got 200 billion okay great
there's 18 trillion in deposits so an
easy solution is drone power riding in
on the White Horse and saying hey move
your deposits from Bank of America over
to the fed and you'll never risk taking
a haircut done deal right that's what
the Average Joe's going to say going to
uh the point that he was making which is
very very good is it it's it's people
need to realize you can't program money
because it doesn't exist just like you
can't program time okay so in order for
them to get the data they need to know
whether Pat ordered a tow food burger at
the restaurant or he ordered a steak
because that's going to go against his
climate scores carbon footprint score
for the month right they have to have
that detailed data right so I've been
talking Robert Barnes the famous lawyer
about this quite a bit and he thinks
that they're going to have the IRS come
in and to get your EIN number you're
going to have to use their point of sale
software and so whether you pay with
Bitcoin or whatever they still could
attach that purchase to your uh the
algorithm that would still crank out
that score you know I took some of my
employees from Columbia to Disney World
because that was on their bucket list
right this weekend when I was in Orlando
and I don't even know if you know this I
was shocked I went in there I bought the
ticket and you know in the old days you
just buy the ticket you give it to the
guy he'd kind of rip it and then you'd
go through the little spindle or
whatever right now what they do is you
you buy the ticket it's got a QR code on
it you go up to the spindle you have to
stop right there they take a picture of
you you then you take your QR code you
scan it then you give them your
fingerprint
you see now whether they're doing this
intentionally or not the bottom line is
they're conditioning people to give
their fingerprint wherever they go right
and so the central planners I think are
going to take advantage of this and say
Hey listen this point of sale software
that you're using in order for me to
take your order at Chipotle just go
ahead and give me your fingerprint and
you can pay with Bitcoin silver gold
dollars I don't care but then once it
goes to your fingerprint it goes to the
IRS it goes on I don't mind that I I I
don't think that I mind that I don't
think that the world should be about tax
evasion and to be honest like you don't
know tax evasion no what they're doing
is they're doing that in order to get
the detailed information as far as what
you're buying because right now if you
go to Chipotle your Wells Fargo
statement shows that you spent 20 bucks
but it doesn't show exactly what you
bought I don't even mind to be honest if
they collect that information about me
like that they don't care if the central
planners and the authoritarians have
that information on every single
American I don't care as long as I
control my spend but if you take that
and you take away my ability to control
my spend that's where the pit like for
me I don't mind record whether I eat too
many nachos or tacos or who the hell
cares as long as you don't control my
spend as long as I have the the right to
do whatever I want with my money but if
you take that and you combine it with
with ownership of my money and telling
me where I can spend and next time I
walk into Chipotle and I want to buy
something it says sorry we have deemed
for some reason that you can't buy this
that's the part that worries me yeah but
that's how they get that's how they
collect the data to determine whether or
not you can buy that in the first place
and you you sound like somebody that
would want as a spokesperson because you
know for us when we're not concerned
about things like that everything starts
off with being sold as it's not a big
deal what's the big deal you know what's
the big deal you know it's not a big
deal we're not trying to do anything and
then all of a sudden it's like well I'm
already doing it anyway so next and next
next some people would even say George
just started with your phone you pick up
your phone and sees your eyes iPhone
boom absolutely you know and then you're
you're in it and so look at the end of
the day cbdc is something that a lot of
people are concerned with and it doesn't
matter whether they're crypto or not
crypto they're concerned about it and uh
I think if there's ever been a time for
us to stay more paranoid as a collective
today's the time to stay more paranoid
than ever before enjoy your life but
stay paranoid because there are some
people that have different motives than
uh I don't think then we do so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign